do you remember when I don't know if you
remember this but when phones for a very
brief period of time had a walkie-talkie
feature on them good good the chirp your
time out and it starts with an N Nextel
Nextel yeah chick chirp only now this is
not a race thing only the black guys oh
my football team have this I've never
seen anyone but a black person with that
I'm sure white people on it this is a
race thing but they would the chirp
chirp just to each other back and forth
and I felt so left out too like oh [ __ ]
I have this [ __ ] razor it doesn't
have it that's it right there's the
razor my going to come back somebody
tell me the flip phones are kind of
making a comeback
they're all the rage for the kids know
if you look at ups I just have one of
those I think dude remember BlackBerry's
on a blackberry yeah they just went away
yeah but those tripped up boop boop
and you have to go back and forth with
each other man I have that mirror the
new iPhone you have yeah it's really
like it I've no desire to get a new
phone it's it's a better camera better
I've never taken a picture of my phone
like dude I wish this was clear I agree
ever I know my brother's saying the same
thing dude look at the screen better
quality pictures dude this thing take
some [ __ ] dope pigs man hey pics dude
you really don't want to Africa and I
didn't I took exactly zero pictures you
really don't take pictures I don't take
you do some videos and I rap party I
love everybody and everybody's taking
pictures it makes sense have memories I
just know you're sociopaths yeah I just
you don't take any pictures I don't look
at them like I don't think about the
past much you don't my phone I have at
the future I have 1800 pictures on my
phone 1,700 are my son the other hand
are you and me probably yes I don't me
on I don't know racing we're still kids
because I want to preserve those let's
stand up pictures right you're annoying
me today well I meet you in the parking
lot you have a lump on your head your
lump on your nose box like Tom Hanks
house Philadelphia I was weird locking
his sorry bro was dead stairs go sorry
bruh Spartan no I did no I did not say
that
I didn't say you go you go whatever your
face and I just what I looked at boring
I said I got punched in the face and you
go that's embarrassing I go yeah well
you got beat up hey Wayne yeah Wayne
McCulloch puts me in there my buddy
Chris I think he won Golden Gloves in
Boston's big [ __ ] Canada he's so
gentle and nice he just moves around
with me and then then my boy Isaac who's
Cuban and just a [ __ ] hell whirlwind
35 how many fights with you
five six six amateur fights yeah doesn't
know what he's doing
why he's better than I am so he punches
me in the face
he'll blast sweet goes hey guess what
you're on this season of this not
happening well I did what what but story
mama yo dude comes out in June okay I
guess man a weird is that kind of stuff
he's strange at the time think so long I
don't know I don't know at the time if
they went hate job you want to do this
what's come out two years later but I'm
like probably not you know what's also
funny is that the materials so old just
changed everything I don't even think
about Comedy Central anymore and they
used to be the kids on the block I
remember having a huge meeting with
Comedy Central I decided to deal with
them now I know it was with Fox but but
it was gonna come around because it
because well I think something with no
and I love Netflix but I think it's so
over saturated so many people are on
there yeah that you can stick out on
kind of central now like you see guys
like Ron Funches comedy special on which
i watch yeah you see yep in it's just
that's then you see promotion on you see
billboards of them with Netflix unless
you're Chris Rock Joe Rogan yeah it's
gonna be tough to get a bill a lot or
any promotion then you go yeah we can
get in the well yeah but have you seen
who's in the queue
yeah you're right the big boys I talked
to her fans have to sneak you out these
days I talked to my marketing people
about that cuz we're gonna do this big
push and it'll be on everything you know
but they were like take a look though
for a second unless you are featured in
that algorithm you get lost in the old
shuffle members of yeah if you're not a
guy guy forgot the this star yeah you
know you know I'm not saying it's a bad
thing but yeah yeah you know think about
it you know it's something to consider
somebody shut your special seven years
ago and I'm proud of you that's coming
out finally thank you buddy any idea
when they're gonna reverse a knife is
the released I'll [ __ ] March ninth it's
going to
this March this Mon man it's about to
get crazy less [ __ ] and he's been
complicated and ap bryan callen stars
stars aware and once it calls that
Netflix and Showtime and it's
complicated no not Nova ape and not oh
I'm sorry did you say hell bleep no
that's someone else's who's much more
famous nobody no no no complicated noble
a complicated hey it's it's the strange
should hire you don't know boys are
complicated a trigger day alright dude
I'm sorry no here it is you'd be
surprised at man oh well dude alright no
this is college giggle fit I do that's
Ron Funches doesn't know no this is
complicated a complicated primate no
complicated Apes yeah it's Apes confused
get ready
by the way taking never grow up and
putting that on YouTube about goddamn
time I am I feel like [ __ ] making
copies about goddamn time
hardly dies when somebody comes I'm goes
dude saw your ostrich pit you know what
I've been doing lately on see when I do
stand others eyes and that writer's
block which is by the way I just lifted
thank God but um I was I was
regurgitating some of my old classics at
the comp line with it yeah I would just
do it it's like old stories that I
forgot about they're like they become
characters yeah
they become like old friends that you
kind of revive it's so [ __ ] funny
it's like singing a song it must be like
how people who sit like you know I don't
know who it is but whatever no because
they still have to do them they still
hey every time the ROI started that was
40 years in Italy and if you think those
[ __ ] hit a stage and not seeing that
you're too goddamn so right there the
crowd will boo you to death yep you
gotta sing the same [ __ ] oh dude oh I
don't know what it is maybe I should
start sucking dick I've been listening a
lot of Backstreet Boys right now you
have know what their newest song is a
smash guys don't want you don't want to
meet
don't want to meet a polar bear that's
not fun okay obviously we know about
crocodiles saltwater Salty's great way
to swim with a salty how many times once
yeah you know go ahead and do yoga on
that [ __ ] great whites you'll probably
be okay but that's not go ahead and
snort me that's the problem that's the
problem with white people they see that
random ass Yogi's have another great
white now you think it's okay right I'll
look at that video she's out her goddamn
mind it has to be a little something
loose David Blaine told me I started
about these two Sciences that were down
they were watching great whites been
swimming of great whites for a long time
they were they were you know filming it
or something and the great white just
turned just went and just went and
turned and grabbed him and swam off
while doing great white [ __ ] yes that's
what great whites do that's right he was
like you know what it's like this
breathing yeah now I'm wearing my scuba
gear they don't know what it is true now
we're all friends we're not threatening
to him that's like a woman otherwise
favorite yeah I was a woman in
Queensland was swimming like in
Australia or whatever Quinn's swim back
to the raft she's on the raft they swam
to raft and then they're swimming kind
of a beautiful abandoned beach swimming
back her husband watched her get bitten
in half by a green black then it came
back and took the rest of her
disappeared I dated a girl 20 years ago
from South Africa you had to go back to
her she had to go back in a hurry
call me very upset her brother-in-law
was with they were on their honeymoon
was with her sister and he got eaten
right in front of her they were swimming
in like you know shoulders and he just
he just she said it came and just she
just saw I literally I know sorry I was
like what am I losing my voice but she
just saw a blood like a just a giant
splash blood and she never saw her like
this it was just a big no though I last
see her I just I just see ya nah
like a chimp through 30 times fast while
talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gets a gift it's a gift